never realizing a Creative Commons
license first of all tell us what that
is what is a Creative Commons license
okay credit columns born out of the
necessity of creators that were using
the work on the internet to be known to
spread the word their work so its
license that goes behind a very very
tight with copyright copyright says
you're right sort of all your own and if
you want to use mega use of that rights
you have to ask for it predacons opens
some of those rights so maybe you want
your movie to be distributed for free to
be sure maybe with a no commercial
purpose or or with the commercial
purpose but you can choose so you had so
many people that they can distribute the
movie or they can share it or copy it or
even roommates it or use the material to
make a new new creative thing so our
idea was that I mean you cannot fight
piracy people is going to share anyway
people are going to copy movies anyway
so why don take advantage of that and
I'm making it legal and allowing them to
copy it share it to four eva marie mix
and use the ideas of the movie and I
will get the revenge from other sites
from other things so that's why we built
this whole distribution new distribution
model elaborated and check it online and
see how we plan to do I'm curious how
are you building your audience before
the film shot what are you doing to gain
interest in the film well the main thing
we tried to do was to be very honest to
share almost everything we were doing
that is why we are very open in our
social networks Facebook Twitter and so
on and we tell our fans an audience
every step we are doing so they can in
one side just what our movies made this
is pray and then on the other one they
can help us with anything we need there
are some times that we need things to to
make the movie possible and they are
there and we can ask me for help that is
amazing so we are telling them how what
we do we have this diary issue from time
to time another blog we tweet personally
as directors and producers and
screenwriters what are we doing and a
lot of things to connect with them
withdraw parties we made a teaser
trailer a lot of things to give them a
glimpse of how the movie will be made do
you have an actual website or you just
using Facebook and a YouTube channel we
have a very very cool website where you
can find everything about the project
take off from out dot org there you can
find the screenplay which is online free
just download it and read it and you can
find a trailer you can find a lot of
information about the community and the
crowdfunding project and the
distribution model everything is open
and also we have twitter and facebook
and blog sure sure and what do you say
to a filmmaker that maybe doesn't have
enough money to have a website i mean i
know you can build your own with Drupal
or WordPress or something but what if
what if somebody doesn't want to do all
that can they just get the word out with
Facebook and Twitter do you think that's
enough or do they have to have an actual
URL it depends what kind of project do
you have my recommendation would be to
have something to show your work and
besides this facebook there are amazing
tools too I mean to build a website
around a blog system like wordpress and
they look like websites and they are
really cool for free so it's not
difficult to build something I think
it's any pic on this necessary but it's
a bender a legitimate in our second last
question okay enough enough answer is it
for anyone that wants to get involved
with the project where do they go well
they it's just a nice to go to the
website the costume out that's possum
out with see with a strap information
the cosmonaut org they there they can
find the whole project the business
model the screenplay trailer the
community and so on and they can access
door to become producers or the blog for
the social